bello a tutti i ragazzi avete questo
video sono famiglie oggi siamo trovati
su minecraft paradise parkour della
prosa ramirez e niente bravi abbiamo qua
qualche la catena figata st ravalle lisa
il fidanzato dell'islam in realtà lo
apprezzo ad acqui dove andare sulla
scala ma si sono la devi saltare dalla e
andare a quella destra perfetto bravo io
da quando arrivano alla scala non ci
arriverò mai ma perfetto ma concentrato
il lo slime se noi si salto direttamente
le scuse ma guarda lì ho saltato
direttamente 60 sulla scala santa su una
scala direttamente sorta di rete salta
di netto qua guarda qua direttamente se
prova visto per ora si esalta su questo
hai finito
bravo pietro grazie neanche la parte
facile ok questo è o non lo so quando ne
ho idea di per sé esserci anche dovrà
darmi una mano
io sono una donna che sbaglio per un
niente porca eva che nervi ciao zio
soltanto davanti non così il primato per
primo tentativo fatto
ok adesso ho fatto devi crederci sono e
poi da qui devi saltare o fatta perfetto
perfetto aiuto come come si sa dov'è la
finale aiuto dove fino a di saltare
sugli altri due a park cava cà porca a
quei minchia fai te tutto sto casino per
per un pezzettino di tronco di un
millimetro
se va beh ma a voi siete scemi come
arrivo alla fine da qua ma non ci posso
arrivare ste pazzi
scherzavamo ce l'ha fatta sarà
fortissimo devi fare tutto in giro
stupido per saltare su un tronco minimi
che una volta questo però devo fare pare
che sei sopra a creare sul cosa verde
poi ancora il corso verde e poi sinistra
c'è un tronco basta voglia di saltare su
questo qua
provaci bravissimo ma sei forte oggi ma
da oggi che succede o un fortissimo
salta non era facile abbiamo fatto tutti
e due al primo tentativo
c'è una specie di roma che passa di
sotto sotto la fontana viene sembrano
liberamente residenti vol à va beh
allora scusami ok
ecco dovrei fare questa cosa l'entrata
di casa mia sarebbe divertente ogni
volta che tra qualche mese da esci per
sta roba non essere stretto vallone
scoppiò cosa mi da qua uno come dovrebbe
a [ __ ] non salta è difficilissima st
parte perché abbastanza pensa che il
rave il campione del mondo aveva finito
il gioco quasi bravo come hai fatto ciò
fatta ce l'ho fatta perfetto da che
parte e qui clore a minchia
io sto entrando li fai te ok la paglia
ti fa saltare di meno no da lì dove mi
chiedo restia andata c'è un'altra scala
come fai a fare il giro
ok non so come ho fatto anche io ma non
puoi saltare dai livelli successivi
subito la c'è un muro invisibile porca
vacca tocca lungo come hai fatto
prendendo devo andare qua quello
all'angolo opposto si sicuro a me sembra
più vicino quello destra
beh per meno male che ti ho ascoltato
per una volta nella vita
perfetto rispetto vieni vieni o per la
lista occhi così se ne va un altro
gigante ma non è no non è però ci fosse
la torre ma ho guardato arredi con dei
ponti incasinata da una mille essere un
passaggio segreto eccolo qui una caverna
grazie alla mia terra
esatto ma un bottone c'è un bottone che
ho schiacciato apple allora perché
qualcosa li valori fallo di farlo è
ancora aperto ok allora facevo visto
lascia la lasciano qua c'è un altro
bottone ho trovato però non so che
bordello è c'è una o mio dio
porca vacca costo vede aiuto non so
spiegare questa cosa fra vieni qua petta
non so come dietro vieni e seguimi le 9
ok ci servono
vieni qua non c'è una specie di roba che
ti spazza in alto tipo così guardate
salta salta il 20 di suo slime perfetta
adessso ke e che spazza evo
ciao amico danger keep out o eccolo e
villa giorno dove perché sente un villa
già da due ore non lo vedo a sentirla
siete fa da un'ora e mezza che fastidio
per il tutor ora che fa è vero sembra
potuto il tutto era un villaggio di
brita esatto parla così ci somiglia pure
ok talora 36 spetta che non ti vedo che
sono sopra l'albero in cima proprio anno
questo è davvero gigante di farli no ma
[ __ ] eva combatto dai o chi è che ha
fatto stato scoperto eccolo
sì ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta posso
fare un solo non bastava saltare 26
basta saltare dritto giuro salta dritto
poche palle ci sono siamo divisi b li
vedo gli altri veli ma non ci posso
andare
c'è un village early comunque da solo
visto andiamo a coccolarlo che solo da
una vita ma senti come si lamenta ma c'è
un passaggio
ok quello dopo e devi passare qua dentro
partecipa arrivare anche l'acqua ok
questa era solo alcuni sono solo
labirinti occhio secco hd un casino come
fai qua scusa è il giro benedica i
blocchi visibili dio santo che kakà che
kakà mamma mia che sta per iniziare da
zero come fai a salire
parlo casacca dei perfetto i miei così
no che sembra una roba romantica non
vorresti mai fare una cosa del genere
con mcrae dove non ci sono delle scale
dentro il fungo è infatti ma che cretino
detto vieni per questo
ok ma scusami come con che fisica
dovreste riuscire a saltare su una scala
dove come non puoi per watt i rami un
cazzo è esatto tirana il mio 3 1 2 3 1 2
3 mila verità di serie vertendo come
come come eccome e non è finito il
livello di richiedere anche una cosa di
pure o nicchia un ora e mezza
che fastidio ma cadeau c'è su questa
roba contanti smeraldo amico lo vedo
grazie molto gentile che me l'hai detto
quando vuoi
c'è un tasto che si schiacciano non
serve a niente ma veritas antistress a
quei salti sei passi la sopra devi farti
il giro tutto un simpatico poi
che poi arrivi di tentare ad altro
livello perfetta tanto vedere come
quello dopo
no vabbè ma non esiste se devi fare
quello che penso qui è impossibile
vabbè no ma infattibile come diavolo
vienna ed e ci sono riuscito come come
come perfetta fatta fatta come hai fatto
pipì latino del parkour il panettone o
fatta cioè fatemi che ci sarà fortissimo
che è bello che ho fatto non lo so
perché c'è una scala li più di quanti ce
n'erano
non so come ho fatto va bene va bene è
stato difficilissimo cos'è sto bordello
qua la vedo così al anche se qua si 106
immortalando cosa serve per avere giusto
per far vedere che siamo capaci lo
faccio anche senza toccare la lava che
casino equa anch'io
sì sì bravo ma basta andare a fuoco
occhio 20th interrompe i salti la lava
poi cosa devi fare
ok perfetto madonna fenomeno da qua il
problema è che il problema è che non
riuscirò a fare niente del resto ma
forse dobbiamo usare il caso dello slam
per al centro o perfetto perché ho un
millimetro maledizione alla vita dai
perfetto
non è vero nel mondo della vita morta
non è vero non posso aver sbagliato
l'ultimo salto da ebeti dai da imbecille
come ho fatto ciò ancora non sia
arrivata una volta lo slide con la
madonna che botta processo
mica sono sentito non so come ha fatto
stare così in alto ok ma la mano veloce
mai fatto se ma mica in procinto di
abbandono ti sta roba
posso andare a vedere cos'è questo
mentre tu fai quello di questa roba qua
scusami ma dove vai no amico
aspetta aspetta ora ho fatto fare
livello del mare
[Musica]